today we're talking about apogee wins
our commitment to eu customers and
vm fleetwide monitoring i'm stephanie
wong and welcome to this week in cloud
where we serve you
the lowest latency news from the safety
of home
apis let developers easily access
combine
and share valuable data and
functionality helping companies adapt to
disruption and reinvent
so partnering with the right api
management vendor is critical
to building and scaling a successful api
program
we're excited to share that gartner has
recognized google
apigee as a leader in the 2020 magic
quadrant for full life cycle api
management
marking the fifth time in a row we've
earned this recognition
in this year's report apogee is placed
highest among
all the vendors for the ability to
execute congrats team
in recent months european customers and
policy makers have placed even more
emphasis
on working with cloud providers to
protect customers most sensitive
information
google cloud has partnered with them to
make significant progress to delivering
more capabilities
for strict data security and privacy
requirements
they reflect three distinct pillars of
data operational
and software sovereignty read thomas
curion's announcement in the blog post
to learn more
you can now monitor your compute vm
fleet's health altogether
the new single pane of glass
infrastructure summary dashboard lets
you see
aggregate fleet wide statistics at a
glance
and provides insight into the top vms
for a select
group of key cpu disk memory and network
metrics jumpstart your troubleshooting
no setup required
check out the blog post to learn all
about it and try it out for yourself
finally the director of product
management of artificial intelligence
has just announced that pytorch
xla support for cloud tpus is now
generally available this means pytorch
users can access
large-scale low-cost tpu hardware
accelerators
using a stable well-supported pytorch
integration
google cloud supports a growing set of
open source implementations of widely
used
deep learning models and associated
tutorials check out our post for
tutorials and how to get started
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud